everyone's armpit stink it's rude not
mine
sweating is a good way to detox may i
have that one go for it
this is a good one smelly foods only
affect your breath this is false hi i'm
dr michelle henry i'm a board certified
dermatologist practicing in manhattan
new york and i'm the founder of skin and
aesthetic surgery of manhattan hi i'm dr
devil bonacelli a board certified
dermatologist here in new york city and
today we'll be debunking myths about
body odor dermatologists are the skin
experts so who knows more about sweat
glands than us sweat is smelly so this
is not true so we actually have two
types of sweat we have sweat that comes
from our e-crying glands and so those
are the glands that are everywhere and
it helps us with thermoregulation so it
helps to cool us down when we're working
out when we're getting too hot and then
we have apricorn glands so those are
sweat glands that we see in areas like
the underarms the groin the chest all
the areas that we sometimes associate
with being smelly but the actual sweat
from the african glands does not smell
why does that area smell it's the
bacteria in those areas so the bacteria
in those areas will use what the gland
produces as food and it's the byproduct
of that that actually smells stinky that
was the most beautiful description of
sweat i've ever heard in my life thank
you i try
so fun fact there are thousands of types
of bacteria and fungus and yeast and
things like that on your body it's
completely normal it's part of our
microbiome so some quick tips to
remember to help with the with the
smelly odor so number one it's okay to
shower every day i promise you number
two is eat a healthy diet you know if
your body is not producing at an optimal
level it will tell you it will show you
and you will smell it if anything
becomes excessive there are certain
medical conditions that do cause it's
okay to go check out and make sure
everyone's armpits stink it's rude not
mine
that is a myth there's actually two
percent of the population that has a
special mutation i believe it's the abcc
11 gene they don't have smelly odors so
not everybody's armpits stink there are
a lot of different treatments for
treating quote unquote smelly armpits
number one you know showering using
antibacterial soap is probably the
easiest hack for all of it we have oral
medications we can give we can have
prescription antiperspirants and we even
use botox i know i know you're going to
be thinking botox like that's for the
other stuff you actually can use botox
to minimize the sweating in the area it
only lasts about three months or so so
you have to kind of come in regularly
but often our patients just do it in the
spring or summer time and then kind of
do their own thing during the winter
time and usually they're fine smelly
feet mean bad hygiene no this is
incorrect smelly feet means smelly feet
doesn't mean bad hygiene we know that
we're producing sweat everywhere and
that sweat then becomes bacteria food
well the feet are really a unique area
it's one of the highest concentrations
of sweat glands on the body and although
there are more kind of acrylic glands in
the african glands and still creating a
moist environment is the perfect
breeding ground for bacteria and yeast
and because our feet are often enclosed
in shoes in dark areas that's literally
yeast food so this is why we see a lot
of fungus and a lot of yeast on the feet
and because of this the feet are going
to be a little bit more prone to having
a smell agreed and it's a very common
thing we see a lot of our athletes gym
rats all those people in between the one
thing i tell my patients always make
sure you wash your feet when you shower
using antibacterial soap is actually a
great idea just make sure everything is
cleansed and you pat dry as quick as
possible before you put on a pair of
fresh socks yes socks are important as
well so wearing cotton socks that are
absorptive and they're going to kind of
lick away that moisture from the feet
that helps a ton your signature scent
never changes this is incorrect and so
just like we are dynamic beings we're
changing our hormones are changing our
micro environments changing our diets
are changing and all these things play a
really critical role in how we smell you
know as we get older and our hormones
change you know we all know that teenage
boys smell a little bit different than
they smelled when they were six and i
wish they could put those like new baby
smells in a bottle oh that would be
amazing
that's my favorite smell remember babies
covered in amniotic fluid for months and
months and months and months you have
this certain scent that people equate to
that new baby smell also as we get older
our skin barriers tend to deteriorate a
little bit and there's more oxidation of
certain things on our skin itself so
that old person smell i hate to say that
it's actually due to
changes in how our skin is protected
from the environment around us and the
oxidation of these certain chemical
compounds can actually cause a specific
scent so next time you go visit your
grandparents things like that just keep
that in mind the more you've been around
a certain smell the more you get used to
it right and so it's really when your
body kind of hits a shock system where
you smell something you're not used to
smelling that's when you kind of form an
opinion about it so just remember if
there's something you don't necessarily
agree with does not mean that it's
incorrect it's just your perception of
that odor and everything kind of going
around that really forms your opinion of
it
sweating is a good way to detox
you may have that one go for it
i don't like that so this is a huge myth
so you know our body is an amazing
machine and 99 of how we detox is
through our liver and our kidneys and
that's why it's really important to keep
those organs very safe that's how we get
rid of all the negative toxins and
byproducts in our bodies your body's job
is to kind of maintain this equilibrium
keep the steady state and that's what
the sweating does it helps you kind of
keep this normalized temperature and so
if you go up too much it's its way of
bringing it back down and while i love a
great sauna it's amazing for my mental
health it's amazing for my relaxation i
know that when i go to asana i'm not
going there to detox so it's really
important that we understand that we
have really effective ways to detox our
body and sweating is not one of them how
crazy are some of these like the
marketing around some of these things i
mean it's believable sometimes i have to
ask myself like i have to revisit my
medical school books
you won't sweat if you put on deodorant
this is a myth so there is a big
difference between deodorant and
antiperspirant deodorant helps to mask
the odor so it helps to reduce the smell
antiperspirants will actually help to
reduce sweating they contain
aluminum-based ingredients that will
clog those pores those glands and help
to reduce sweating one thing about
natural deodorants is that sometimes
they can have a lot of salts and other
ingredients that can be a little bit
harsh on the skin so sometimes it's a
little bit of trial and error to find
the right natural deodorant for you
deodorants with ingredients like
ceramides to help to protect and fortify
the skin barrier deodorants with
ingredients like vitamin b5 which helps
to soothe the skin and reduce
inflammation ingredients like you know
coconut oil which also can help to kind
of soothe the skin use it for two weeks
and decide if it's good for you or not
the idea becomes once you find a good
deodorant stick to it if you keep
switching things up and moving things
you're going to have more of an
inclination for having a reaction or
having some issue with tolerability
here's a fun hack for you if you're
using an antiperspirant you can actually
put it on at night time to get a better
overall result and less sweating
throughout the course of your day at
night time our sweat glands are not as
active so that those aluminum-based
ingredients can actually clog the pores
a little bit better put it on during the
day when you're already active then
something's blocking them and they can't
really settle as well as they can at
night antiperspirant is dangerous
so what do you do when you hear all
these people say that aluminum causes
cancer and it's dangerous and all that
kind of stuff yes so i give them a
little science lesson so the presence of
an ingredient does not necessarily mean
causation for instance during the winter
months i start drinking tea it makes me
feel warm i also tend to get colds in
the winter months does that mean the
warm tea caused my cold you know so the
presence of something or the correlation
does not always mean causation so what
we see is that when we biopsy breast
tissue breast tissue that's in the area
around the underarm which is a common
area where we do see breast cancer we
will see aluminum
there in that tissue it's there because
it's adjacent to where we're using
aluminum containing ingredients however
currently we do not have data showing
that it causes cancer and while many
feel that they're uncomfortable with
that they can choose to use other
options but right now we do not have
data showing that aluminum containing
ingredients specifically contribute to
breast cancer so why aluminum well
aluminum is currently the only fda
approved antiperspirant ingredient
that's not to say that there are other
alternatives out there for you if you're
more comfortable choosing them but it's
just always important to educate
yourself and continue to monitor the
data moving forward and part of our job
as doctors is to understand where the
fear comes from and then look for
alternatives right really you should
only do what's comfortable for you and
what you feel you're okay doing on a
day-to-day basis so if you block all the
sweating from the armpit area do you
sweat in other places more well that is
another common question i get that a lot
when we do botox in those areas the
truth is we have so many sweat glands
that it kind of just distributes evenly
and so the idea becomes again the sweat
does come out at some point somewhere so
we just minimize the amount in an area
where the bacteria might be feeding on
it to create more of the odor or the
scent oh this is a good one smelly foods
only affect your breath false so we know
that foods can affect your breath but it
can also affect your body we know that
some of those foods especially those
cruciferous foods like cabbage
cauliflower broccoli can affect how we
smell overall that produces sulfuric
acid that's so that's similar to that
rotten egg smell that we all know and
the same with red meat there are some
studies showing that those that eat a
lot of red meat may smell a little bit
different eating lots of fish will
produce a byproduct called
trimethylamine that's right
trimethalosaurus and so that's a very
characteristic smell alcohol produces
acetic acid which you can also smell and
we do excrete
components of our food which then will
interact with the bacteria and we will
smell differently because of that so
there might be certain foods that might
alter your smell in some way shape or
form but just remember always have a
healthy balanced diet and don't let the
scent of what may come afterwards
dictate any part of that as a girl who
loves cauliflower pizza and all things
cauliflower i have yet to let that
cruciferous smell keep me from eating it
i don't think i smell no not at all
listen cauliflower pizza no joke
so good generally i've learned in life
everybody is different and it's okay to
accept that i think what we're
highlighting more than the fact that the
smell is good or bad is that the smell
is different to someone else it smells
like home it smells like all the
goodness that they know and so we need
to always keep that perspective when we
encounter new people and new
environments
because it's a personal experience i
like the idea of smelling like home i'd
like you guys to take away that being a
little stinky sometimes is normal it's a
part of being a human it's a part of the
human experience be kind to yourself be
kind to others but also if you find that
it's outside of what's normal for you
talk to your dermatologist talk to your
family physician figure out what's going
on but give yourself grace because we're
all a little stinky sometimes